all right I read Tim Keller shells
column as I always do but this one you
know stood out we some numbers there had
to do with dak Prescott and I then I saw
where Troy Aikman said you need a
complete overhaul lot of dysfunction
there describing his former team Tim
Couch Sean joins us now would you go
that far Tim complete overhaul a lot of
dysfunction there oh I would go far as
to say it and I and I think several of
us have said it before but complete
overhaul suggests you're gonna have a
different system than Gerry and Steven
being at the center of all the
decision-making and I just don't think I
don't think there's anything you can do
to convince Jerry that that's not the
way to go it doesn't matter how long it
goes between Super Bowls
he still is going to believe that this
his system works so I try saying it has
a lot of impact because I mean now that
was a pretty obvious rip of of Jerry
Jones and the way he manages general
managers this team but I don't think
it's going to change it if you're a
Dallas fan and here we are at the
halfway point what numbers can you point
out that would give hope to maybe
turning this around I did want to see
you negative you know early but yes well
Lamar he was 5 for 58 how's that that's
hope hope for a brighter day I mean
there isn't a lot what you would say is
this the only hope for for now is the
NFC East and if you can convince
yourself hey go beat the Eagles you're
both 4 and 5 the Redskins just put half
their offense on injured reserve you're
fundamentally tied for 1st and you can
play Washington again to take care of
them so if you can believe now they the
Cowboys play the Eagles twice in the
next five games so they would have to
sweep them really to make this hope work
but but all the numbers about the team
about dak about the offensive line
Zeke they all stink there's those are
not numbers of oak if I said to Dallas
fans you can have your team at 8 and 8
or
five and eleven and at five and eleven
you're getting a new coach well they
would take they would take the five at
11:00 but I don't I don't think you have
to go that far I mean I think it's I
think if they are not in the playoffs
Gerry Jonesy they've got changed and you
just talked about him giving a vote of
confidence to doc he's really giving a
vote of confidence
- Jason gear of the staff he's just
saying I'm not making any changes during
the season he doesn't go beyond that so
I think seven nine I think eight and
eight if you missed the playoffs
probably isn't good enough either but
definitely fear question
fans we talked about this yesterday on
the radio right I don't think they've
ever had a coach is disliked the Cowboys
have never had a coach is disliked is
Jason Garrett Wade Phillips one disliked
like that Switzer at the end was kind of
thought of as a joke but nobody is I
mean they saw him on Dodger Stadium and
people would not humor so I mean it's
just they want him off their screams now
is this an attractive John like if I
said you could have the Cowboys job
current regime in place or you could be
the head coach of the Cleveland Browns
if I'm Lincoln Riley and I wanted to go
to the NFL which I don't know that he
does but let's say I do and I have to
look at those two I would have to leave
for Cleveland because I would have to
lean toward John Dorsey being a proven
GM and they had to had some good draft
picks and I got Baker Mayfield or
working with Jerry working with Stephen
and working with dak Prescott and right
now I think dak Prescott is a very big
unknown at best and and I thought it was
funny in the broadcast Monday night both
him and Mary Mariota they talked a lot
about they Mariota has to stop making
these plays he's in his fourth year
Dax in his third year they're not going
to just suddenly stop doing dumb things
and making these mistakes and missing
open receivers that's that's kind of who
they are
so I would lean towards Cleveland that's
crazy to say but given those parameters
and those quarterbacks I think that's
the more attractive job
why did Jerry learn out that you know
he's extending dak Prescott like why do
that now yeah there's no need to do that
Jerry is one of those people who tries
to diffuse an argument by saying more
than you think he's going to and wow
he's really emphatic on this well back
off and instead he just starts with new
a new discussion he's extending back
there already making that decision I
mean really Dax only hope at this point
and you hate to say only hope you know
the way you look two years ago but his
only hope is the coaching change after
this year obviously a coordinator change
and whoever that is next year in his big
year is fourth year things start to look
better and they can do that otherwise
it's I don't know how low an extension
you know you think they think they're
gonna make but given the agent changed I
just made I mean he's not looking for a
low low cowboy friendly contract and his
next time around
yeah but he's either your quarterback or
not no matter what the price is here
okay so even if you're getting at a
bargain price you still your starting
quarterback and is that who you want as
your franchise quarterback moving
forward right and if that's the other
part that if you have a new coach coming
in well he may want a different
quarterback you've already traded your
first-round pick for Amari Cooper so
you're not going after any of the any of
the biggest guys do you like somebody in
the second or third round that you think
can compete right away or are you going
to go you know but the quarterbacks who
tend to be on free agency or usually the
scrapheap type quarterbacks man Dez
Bryant with the Saints and how
surprising is that if if that's gonna
happen here that he's gonna sign which
it looks like he's going to Manoa that's
a great Drew Brees and that they talked
about Michael Thomas being the most
precise route runner in the NFL and Drew
Brees throws it right to this spot and
that's really not there's a deal but
having said that they
they don't I don't think that even using
Cameron Meredith these days they don't
really even have a third wide receiver
they'd like to use so it'd be an
opportunity to just pay just come in and
occasionally make a play we're not
expecting a lot but just come out and
play you know it's worth a shot for them
and it's it's it's great for DES because
he's sat out the entire year and all of
a sudden this falls into his lap yeah
when I get a ring out of it hey Tim good
to talk to you again and thanks for
stirring it up we appreciate your time
as always all right Timmy that's Tim
Couch a Dallas Morning News for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]